about all that's in the way from getting
married but to be honest there's not
gonna be much of a difference in us
getting married in reality legally
there's gonna be a lot of changes but in
reality we're already living together
it's gonna be the same
yeah that's i've never had a issue with
a prenup i don't know why people get
emotional about it because if your plan
is to say mary then what does it matter
yeah that's what i said so i follow this
lady on instagram at take the love pill
she really breaks down femininity and
masculinity
and
because of women's hypergamous nature a
prenup is not necessarily a bad thing
because you get the resources if you
stay
but you also get resources if you if you
try to leave and it's actually very hard
to have an airtight prenup but as a
woman you can put things in there to
advocate for yourself your prenup
doesn't just have to be about his
security it can be about your security i
can't get into details about mine but
there's things that happen after five
years 10 years stuff like that
financially on my part and people would
say well if you're a woman and you get
married you're just supposed to stay
married and if you leave then you get
nothing i don't think anybody ever plans
for the death of a child and very few
people's marriages can survive that so i
mean i think we're just doing what is
sensible mm-hmm
well and uh
if a guy loves you he's not gonna want
to leave you high and dry like even
donovan on his channel he said like if
me and devin don't work out like i would
financially help her the rest of her
life
like like guys don't want to just leave
you
like they're not these evil men that
just want to
okay yeah i i i know you're all good i
know probably having some wild people up
in her up in her apartment
i thought somebody knocked on my door
and it scared me but i think it was just
the storm
you know when you when you do that it
looks like a horror movie like if
somebody's just about to like come in
and snatch it
oh
um in any case
yeah if a man loves you he does not want
to leave you high and dry you really
think so like
i like to believe that my fiance is not
a sociopath but every woman who's ever
been killed by one didn't know okay i'm
i am betting my money statistically
speaking that he's not a sociopath it
would crush him if he just left me and i
was homeless on the street or something
you know but that's all based out of
fear because women are coming women come
to me and they tell me that i'm taking a
risk by financially depending on my
fiance because we're not married but if
you know enough about the family courts
and common law marriage he's assuming a
lot of risk but women don't know that
because we're sort of pedestalized
everything is sort of
um we're we're the ones that are we're
having our time wasted couldn't be then
possibly wasting his time nobody
everybody thinks about that they just
think about the automatic assumption is
that men are bad or we're trying to take
advantage of us
well and what could you talk a little
more about that because i actually did
not know that he assumes risk by having
you like live there and financially
depend on him so yeah talk more about
man oh girl okay okay so i'll tell you
i'll tell you um
right so
when you want to look at the possibility
of what can happen in the united states
you want to look at the uk and the uk is
much more woke than what we have in the
us
so you can live with a man for a few
months
and in some instances there have been
rulings that that constituted a
common-law marriage so basically the man
is cohabitating with his girlfriend
they break up
she instead of breaking up
initiates a divorce do you see
and each state what they have that
indicates a common-law marriage will
vary so in the state of kansas which
shout out to the midwest that's where i
live way too much gluten in this air so
here
if you call each other husband and wife
and you're not legally married or you
didn't do a church ceremony that
constitutes common law marriage
so you actually have to be careful about
the words that you call each other how
you have your big accounts linked and
for what
i get so worried about this information
ending up in the hands of a gold digger
i get so worried but i'll just i will be
transparent if you have a man
directly paying for a large bill for you
like let's say it's a car payment maybe
it's car insurance maybe it's rent so
the bill is in your name
but the payment is coming from his bank
account with his name
that can be enough for a woman to ask
for a common law divorce whether you've
been together for six months maybe
you've been together for several years
so it it varies
yeah so it's like people like oh my god
you're taking so much risk like yeah my
eggs but i'm 27. like
i do want to have a baby as soon as
possible though so
well and it's not like you're doing
nothing like you're building a business
right now
like you're getting the opportunity to
build like the business that you want
oh yeah i'm so tired of these horror
stories like people out here really
looking at the color purple and think of
that as everybody's relationship or
waiting to exhale i mean i don't know i
don't know if you know i mean i'm a
little bit more ethnic for those of you
that don't know i'm puerto rican but i
also grew up in a
yeah my stepfather was black so i i got
the best of both cultures really so it's
just like these terrible horror stories
about what if a man takes advantage of
you nobody talks about what happens if
you're cherished
like let me tell you this so i just
started this femininity journey because
i
wan i'm very much a try it out see if it
helps you kind of girl and i tried it
out because i wanted to be becky
housewife i'm not going to front i
wanted that and so i had to do research
and i tried it out for two weeks and i
was getting a lot of responses from him
positive feedback so positive feedback
gives you that positive reinforcement so
i just kind of kept doing it but he
started opening doors for me all the
time
every time like
all the time the door's getting open
left and right he's always making sure i
have water baby are you thirsty stuff
like that so
you know all these nightmare stories
just tell me you picked the wrong dude
without telling me you picked the wrong
one
well it makes it
it makes you look bad because you're the
one who chose him but and and here's the
thing they don't talk about like men are
so willing to help you like
my brothers i could talk like on and on
about how how many times they've just
like helped me with random situations in
my life that's why i could never hate
that because my brothers are like
literally like when covet first happened
i was supposed to run a marathon and it
got canceled and my older brother austin
i was in i'd moved to milwaukee and
didn't know anyone right
he he has all his friends run with me
and he organizes like the whole trail so
i can like run it the whole and it was
just so nice i didn't even ask him to
it's just like stuff like that like men
are so willing to help you if you're you
know nice to them and a pleasant person
to be around
yeah yeah it's true like
learning how to work with men and just
be grateful for their assistance
will do wonders for you professionally
as well it's not just
for you know keeping your man happy and
things like that although that's what
works for me and i look i get it like
not every woman wants to be the kind of
housewife that i want to be i understand
that maybe they want to work maybe they
want to have a career that's fulfilling
look
i'm just here to help women who want to
get married and stay married i look at
traditionalism as insurance but in
regards to
men just being helpful for you
i would say that
a lot of my professors is predominantly
male and i'm establishing better working
relationships with them all the time
just because i do say that i'm grateful
for masculinity
and it's interesting because the more i
talk to them about inner gender dynamics
they don't really they don't really
disagree with me they pretty much agree
that women like resources not one of
these masculine professors because
they'd be like masculine in the closet
or something i don't know they're all
ripped but yeah it's it's a good thing
to
try out and see if it works for you as a
woman actually i'm curious if you agree
with this i
i say it's not necessarily about the
money okay
like if a guy won the lottery if he's
broke wins the lottery